many times in modern media i find myself
gravitating towards the less popular or
the underrated characters
those characters who receive the screen
time but aren't talked about as much as
the main character would be
as they have this really insane
potential to go practically anywhere
within the story
in a typical bad guy versus good guys
scenario the main character usually
plays the hero who defeats the bad guy
at the end in contrast
that side character can either pursue
their own aspirations utterly different
from the main character
by providing a supporting role to the
rest of the cast or being a roadblock in
the protagonist's fate
all this ties into ryuzo a side
character with endless outcomes as we as
the player get to experience why he
chose the path he did
we don't get to meet ryuzo later until
the end of act one gin is tasked with
recruiting a wide variety of individuals
one of which is the straw hat ronin
where a story begins
in the kishi grasslands we find a
burning tree in a dismantled cart it
seems like a mongol convoy who was
ambushed which is strange but a possible
lead to the straw hats see the straw
hats aren't some simple townsfolk who
just know how to fight in combat
within the description of their outfit
it says individuals who live
and die by the bow and blade the ambush
and the aftermath of the fighting we
discover
is their forte the trail of footprints
found near the scene leads to a forest
with dead mongols and the lonely straw
hat
upon picking up the hat jen is attacked
by a mongol which is then saved by a
straw hat ronin
this specific straw hat is the leader of
the group called ryuzo
not only is he the only named straw hat
thus making him an essential character
to us
he's also important to jyn as this is
his old friend
jyn and ryuza were friends when they
were younger but it wasn't all perfect
back then there was a tournament being
held this was to see the new generation
of talent that the lords of the clans
within the samurai could use for their
clans by adopting them into the family
if they wanted to kind of like how shima
are playing to do with jin later in the
game
rizu had personally invited some of the
lords to watch as he was a lonely
fighter and was fighting the heir to the
clan sakai
jin and this was his opportunity to
prove himself specific actions and
events though would cause this to not be
successful for reuse though this was
jin's first tournament so he was very
thrilled to fight and went all out right
from the start
which gave ryuzo a lousy look as he lost
fairly quickly
on top of this defeat the clans were
more interested in what the future of
clan sakai had as opposed to some
no-name fighter not only because jin was
part of a clan within the island already
which gave him more status than ryuzo
but mostly due in part that jin was
already going to be a samurai and if by
some reason the island got into a civil
war
the clans need to know the strength of
the other rival clans even though they
stuck together during the invasion it's
not uncommon for a clan to feel
indifferent about its position compared
to others
maybe they have the worst terrain on the
island or always hit the hardest
politically it only takes one person to
start a war so this tournament to some
could be used as a gathering of intel
regardless though ryuzo was not happy
with this outcome and still continually
brings it up to jhin even now
because this re-user needs to find
mercenary rick to try to prove himself
and to others that he was capable of
being a samurai so he joined the straw
hats and later became the leader fast
forward back to the present day
ryuzo and jin are having a little
reunion after their encounter with some
mongol forces to discuss their plans
at this moment as explained before jin
is looking for allies to save lord
shimra
the problem is that ryuzo needs help
their numbers are shrinking and those
few members they have left
are starving so jin proposes a plan if
they find enough food to survive the
straw hats will then help jin save
shimra as a sign of thanks
riza was hesitant as his men are all he
has but ends up agreeing but only on the
terms they find the food first you then
arrive at the straw hat encampment to
discuss the plans on how to get the
group the food they need
it's discovered here that the straw hats
were at komoda beach but the only reason
they lived
is that they ran away when it got rough
while this is a small detail it reveals
that ryuza doesn't really carry the same
codes of virtue that jin follows being a
samurai
as leader reuses men are his top
priority no matter the cost
the small instances we see of this in
the beginning is the game's way of
foreshadowing what lies ahead
jin then arrives at taku-sudama cemetery
where he meets ryuzo to discuss the
intel his straw heads have discovered
about the nearby base
the plan is to infiltrate the lighthouse
on the nearby hill to prevent
reinforcements from coming off shore
upon clearing the lighthouse it is found
that the dock they are near
is only for transport the food is being
stationed there so they can ship it
offshore
so the straw hats distract the mongols
while jin and reuse those sneak onto the
ship to find the food they were shipping
once again ryuza comes back empty-handed
is after searching all the boats in the
bay
none had any food all isn't lost though
as the document with mongol battle plans
is found which could lead to some of the
supply lines containing some food later
then jin eventually goes to kamatsu
forge and takes it from mongol control
out of the blue ryuzo shows up and asks
chin for help rizzo's men use the battle
plans they seized from the previous
encounter and got outnumbered and
captured
but strangely enough the straw hats were
singing people who are captors don't
usually sing while in captivity you
follow ryuza and the rest of the straw
hats who weren't captured to for yatate
the plans to sneak in
rescue the straw hats then ambush
mongols when everyone is free this is a
relatively simple task as now with the
straw hats being reunited you overwhelm
the mongols with ease after talking with
ryuza the reason for their singing
within captivity is due to them being
fed food as we stated before the straw
hats are surviving so a feast of some
excellent food is worthy of a
celebration
with everything all set and ready though
jin with his new allies take the forward
to castle canada
except there's just one problem upon
arriving everyone has shown up
except the straw hats the problem is
that there's no time to wait so the
attack continues without their support
the reason they aren't at the front
gates with jinn is that they've already
infiltrated the castle themselves
except for the wrong reason the khan has
placed a bounty on jyn's head
and anyone can claim it ryuzo accepted
the offer but he still needs food for
his men
jin tries to convince him to have him
join his side once more but ryuzo knows
that even if he does and becomes the
samurai
he'd be leaving his men defend for
themselves and probably just get sent to
his death like a komoda beach and ryuza
does not want that to happen
so joining the khan is his only viable
option gina ryuzo duel within the walls
of the castle
jin then defeats ryuza but leaves him
alive and wounded
jin gives him one final chance to
surrender and join his side
but ryuza declines once more alerting
the castle of jin's position and
escaping to the gate
this is the very last chance ryozo had
but still chose to stick with his
previous decision
there's no more going back on this as
jyn and ryuzo are no longer friends and
the next time they meet
one is leaving alive the rest of this
encounter is played out normally with
jin rescuing lord shimra and securing
the castle we get a glimpse of what
ryuzo is now dealing with as a result of
his decision which is attacking villages
and forts with the khan and killing
people as a way to get them to surrender
riza seems displeased with his actions
he has taken but he knows not only can
he not go back on his word now
he also understands that he and his men
need to survive and proving his worth to
the khan is the only way to do so after
capturing the castle ryuzo takes a back
seat in terms of some screen time but
there is one dialogue that is shown
between ryuzo and kotun khan which talks
about the khan's order to kill jin
rizo initially refuses but khan
pressures him into accepting
reason that comes up with a plan that
involves him not being killed
this leads us to the end of act 2 right
before the assault on castle shimra
jin receives a word from schumer that
the straw hats plan to flank the samurai
when they attack and that jin needs to
deal with this
issue before they can proceed with the
assault jin then enters the stronghold
to find ryuza they talk for a bit before
jin is knocked out unconscious and taken
captive along with taka who joined jin
in an attempt to prove himself that he
isn't just a liability and he can hold
his own this capture of course leads to
taka's death and jin's ruthless
emotion-filled slaughter of the rest of
the camp's occupants
the conclusion of this story though
comes at the end of the raid of the
castle
jyn after poisoning the guards the
castle walks up to the stairs to the
main building
and hopes to find kotoon khan but
instead finds ryuzo in his place
this then starts the final encounter
with ryuzo that jin will have rizzo
tells jin
that he doesn't want to fight this time
very opposite rules compared to the last
fight they had
jyn doesn't accept as ryuza was an
accomplice in taka's death
rizzo comes up with ideas to make it
believable that he wasn't a traitor but
jin won't budge
rizzo is a criminal and he must pay for
his crimes with this comes the last
battle between the two with ryuza being
killed as a result this ends the tale
between ryuzo
and jin it's a sad tale though rizzo
being a jin side would have been really
incredible especially at the ending of
the game
but of course the two of them had
different priorities which led him down
this path that would ultimately be his
last let me know what you think about
this encounter though between these two
in the comments down below
as always i want to thank you all for
joining me on this journey of two old
friends doing all they can to survive
of course but with different ideals that
force them to cross paths and confront
one another so that the victor may
continue to survive and do what they
think is right thank you for watching
the video though like and subscribe if
you enjoyed these narrative commentaries
and i'll hopefully see you all in a
future video
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
you